opioids are drugs that have been used
for millennia they've been used for the
treatment of pain they've been used for
spiritual purposes and for recreational
purposes because opioids can provide
effective pain relief they can also
produce a euphoria opioids are drugs
that come from opium and it was about
200 years ago that a German chemist
figured out how to isolate one of the
more potent molecules in opium the sap
from the opium poppy what this chemist
figured out how to do was to isolate
morphine and it didn't take very long
for morphine to begin to make its way
into many different medical products
products that were either prescribed or
in some cases sold over-the-counter it
was in the mid-1800s that the United
States began to experience its first
opioid crisis this was an epidemic of
opioid addiction that was developing
because the population in the US was
becoming over exposed to opioids you had
Civil War soldiers who were becoming
addicted to morphine that was prescribed
to them but you also had many
middle-class middle-aged housewives who
were becoming addicted to morphine you
had many doctors who had as the business
model for their medical practice
prescribing lots of morphine they these
were doctors who might have patients
visiting their office multiple times a
day to receive a morphine injection by
the late 1800s the opioid addiction
epidemic had grown severe overdose
deaths involving morphine had risen to
very high levels and there was an
awareness among health officials across
the United States about the risks and
dangers of products containing morphine
it was in the midst of that morphine
epidemic that the Bayer corporation
introduced a new opioid called heroin
and when the Bayer corporation
introduced heroin it actually promoted
heroin as a safer alternative to
morphine there was lots of concern about
overdose risk with morphine and so
heroin was promoted as having a lower
risk of overdose death than the Bayer
corporation pointed to studies that they
had done in mice to try and show that
there was less risk of overdose death
from decreased breathing we'll probably
never know whether or not those studies
were done incorrectly or whether it was
all made up as part of a marketing
strategy but we do know that heroin is
not safer than morphine
shortly after heroin was released onto
the market we began seeing a new type of
opioid addiction problem we began seeing
young Americans particularly in urban
areas begin using heroin non-medically
these were young white street toughs in
New York City they were the children of
immigrants they were Italian Irish
Jewish they were purchasing
pharmaceutical-grade heroin tablets
crushing them and snorting them and so
we began to see this overlapping
epidemic of opioid addiction in
non-medical users of prescription
opioids by 1914 the problem had grown so
severe that the federal government
stepped in and began passing laws to
better regulate the sale and prescribing
of narcotics
after these laws were passed we began to
see a decline in opioid addiction it
wasn't until after world
or to that the United States faced its
next opioid addiction epidemic this time
it's an epidemic that's
disproportionately affecting inner-city
non-white populations and the opioid is
black market illicit Lee manufactured
heroin and because the heroin that's
coming into inner-city communities has
been cut so many times before it reaches
a user it's heroin that can really only
have an effect in people who inject it
so this becomes an injection heroin use
epidemic that hits low-income non-white
communities very hard and that's in the
1970s it wasn't until 1996 that the next
opioid addiction epidemic begins and
that next epidemic is the one that we're
dealing with today and the epidemic were
dealing with today is far worse than any
drug addiction epidemic the United
States has faced previously when we look
at the number of people affected and the
number of overdose deaths that we're
experiencing when we talk about our
opioid problem or when we talk about the
opioid crisis it's important to frame
the problem in the right way our opioid
problem I believe is an epidemic of
opioid addiction meaning that the reason
that we're experiencing record high
levels of overdose deaths involving
opioids and the reason that we're seeing
heroin flood into communities where it
wasn't previously available and the
reason we're seeing soaring rates of
infants born opioid dependent and all of
the different health and social problems
that the driver has been a sharp
increase in the number of Americans
suffering from opioid addiction the CDC
has been very clear about the cause of
our current opioid addiction epidemic
but the CDC has shown is that as
prescriptions for opioids began to
increase rapidly beginning in the 1990s
as the prescribing went up it led to
parallel increases in rates of addiction
and overdose deaths so what the CDC has
really been saying is that this is an
epidemic that has been caused
inadvertently by the medical community
over prescribing opioids as the
prescribing went up it led to an
epidemic of addiction and overdose
deaths now the reason that the medical
community began to prescribe opioids
much more aggressively starting in the
1990s has a lot to do with the way in
which opioids were marketed it was in
1996 that oxycontin was introduced and
the drug company that manufactures
oxycontin when it put the medication on
the market it launched a campaign to
encourage opioid prescribing the
manufacturer of oxycontin wanted to see
the drug used for common conditions but
they had a problem back in the early 90s
many doctors understood that opioids are
highly addictive and we understood that
there are limitations to using them for
chronic non-cancer pain we knew that if
you put a patient on opioid chronically
that the risk of addiction would go up
if patients taking the opioid long-term
we knew that patients would very quickly
develop a tolerance to the pain
relieving effect meaning that they would
need higher and higher doses in order to
get pain relief and we knew that even if
a patient didn't clearly get addicted
the physiological dependence that would
set in
would make it hard for many patients to
ever come off of opioid so in the early
90s the medical community understood
that opioid should be prescribed
cautiously for chronic pain we knew
these are essential medicines for
end-of-life care and essential medicines
to be used short-term for severe pain
for example after major surgery but we
knew better than to use them
aggressively for conditions like low
back pain chronic headache fibromyalgia
but when oxycontin was introduced the
manufacturer reframed these very good
reasons for being cautious with opioids
as barriers to compassionate pain care
in educational programs that were
sponsored by the drug company 20,000
educational programs in the first six
years of the release of oxycontin
doctors began to hear that the risk of
addiction had been overblown that we've
been allowing patients to suffer
needlessly that we can be much more
compassionate if we prescribe opioids
more liberally and we didn't just hear
this in educational programs that were
sponsored by drug companies we heard
these messages from our professional
societies from our hospitals for more
state medical boards so from every
direction primary care doctors begin
hearing that if you're an enlightened
physician and a concerned compassionate
physician you'll be different from those
stingy puritanical doctors of the past
that were allowing patients to suffer
needlessly and so as we responded to
this brilliant campaign and as the
prescribing increased it led to the
epidemic that we're dealing with today